welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to I'm away on my wedding
anniversary at the moment so
unfortunately I won't be posting up any
breakdowns or new releases but I thought
I'd use the time to break down the
ending of one of my favorite horror
films it follows whether it was the
amazing synth sound track or phenomenal
feeling of dread that you have
throughout the movie something about
this film always stuck with me
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down the main part of the film it's
ending and giving my thoughts and what
the mysterious monster represents this
is full spoilers ahead so if you don't
want to know anything about the film
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now but everyone else I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video I hope you enjoy it now sit back
relax and let's get into my ending
explain breakdown of it follows it
follows centers around J and adolescent
female that after having sex with the
boy named Hugh learns that she's been
infected with a sexually transmitted
demon or STD that slowly follows her
throughout the film if the demon manages
to catch up to her it will kill her and
then begin making its way unto Hugh
before it works its way down the line
killing those until he reaches the
source Jay learns that the curse can be
passed on to others through intercourse
but doing so will doom them and if it
manages to kill them then it will once
more put her in the crosshairs
the creature is invisible to all those
who are not infected however it does
have a physical body and with the help
of friends Jay is able to seemingly
defeat the creature once and for all in
the end Paul a close friend of Jay that
has always desired her decides to make a
pact and the two couple up passing the
curse back and forth between one another
we end on an ambiguous shot of the two
hand-in-hand both clearly in a world of
despair but forced into a relationship
in order to survive whilst the creature
may or may not still be stalking it so
the biggest question that I always see
surrounding this film is did they kill
the creature and what does the final
shot mean well firstly
I don't believe that they did at the
beach though it was damaged the monster
still kept coming back and due to this
the swimming-pool plan in my mind won't
really make a difference beyond delaying
it the entity has no fear of
confrontation and therefore we can
surmise that it is unable to be harmed
thus this final defeat is a teens dream
and now they have found a way to make
the creature manageable it will
eventually come back around like all the
STDs that people who thumbs down this
video have sorry about that
the final coupling up is not a good idea
and it's probably going to cause more
complications down the line that will
eventually lead to further problems this
is like on love island when people
couple up to stay in the show and know
they're going out at some point but they
just want a couple more weeks in the
spotlight and that's what Jay and Paul
are doing she's basically having to
resort to Paul to stay alive for a bit
longer and we all know that the plan
will not work forever this was confirmed
by the director David Robert Mitchell
who when discussing the film with
vulture said the following it's the
stupidest plan ever it's a kids movie
plan it's something that scooby-doo and
the gang might think of and that was
sort of the point what would you do if
you were confronted by a monster and
found yourself trapped within a
nightmare ultimately you have to resort
to some way of fighting it that's
accessible to you in the physical world
and that's not really going to cut it we
kind of avoid any kind of traditional
setup for that sequence because in more
traditional horror films there might be
a clue that would lead them to figure
out a way to destroy this monster I
intentionally avoided placing those
instead they do their best to accomplish
something and we witness its failure
it's probably a very non-conventional
way of approaching the third act
confrontation but we thought it was a
fun way to deal with it in regards to
the final shot and the figure stalking
Jay and Paul he stated we had a couple
of variations on it I think we had some
where he was really far back and then
some where no one would ever miss him
but we settled on the one where he's
there but not too close it allows people
to make up their own mind of what it
means to me it means that this will
forever linger over their relationship
and they can either mature to the point
that they will be equipped to deal with
it or it will cause them to turn
each other though demons aren't often a
problem in a relationship that develops
from your late teens into your 20s it
can be viewed more as a metaphor for
other things that pop up teenage
relationships are simple carefree and
often feel like non-stop fun however
upon graduating school moving out or
having to step into the real world they
often fall apart you to neither member
of them being equipped to deal with the
problems that they now face I know from
my personal experience that in my early
20s though all my relationships started
off well as a couple we simply were not
compatible as people to work together as
one in order to tackle actual issues
which eventually caused us to separate
this is the situation that Jay and Paul
now find themselves in and they must
either mature and get through the
problem or fall apart because of it but
what exactly is the monster well it's
difficult to fully comment on what
exactly this shape-shifting entity is
however I believe that it is a
manifestation of sexual assault and the
stigmatism that surrounds it Jay
experiences assault early on in the film
however she confronts this and after
opening up to her friends and finding a
caring sexual partner is able to
overcome the threat of it though we
learn little in the film about the
previous victims of the entity from what
information that we do get it's clear
that they tackled it in the opposite way
to Jay Hugh move to a dilapidated
building and pass it on without
discussing it Jay on the other hand
freely discusses it and this allows her
to confront the issue head-on without
judgment Greg who willingly takes on the
demon from Jay doesn't really seem to
believe in it and instead he uses it as
an opportunity to have sex with Jay
juxtaposing this Paul actually wants to
help with her problems and he seems like
a nice guy willing to be there this
leads to Greg being killed and
ultimately Jay is left in the same
situation as she was before passing it
on there comes a big turning point in
the film when Jay has the opportunity to
sleep with a group of men on the boat
however I think that she realizes that
this is wrong and returns home this is
the opposite to Hugh and likely the ones
before him who knowingly pasta on and
Durst led to more mystery in the finale
of the film the creature appears as Jays
father and personally I think that this
represents the parents
approval that may center around the
subject of their child's sexual activity
by killing the monster as it is in this
form Jay is able to fully shed the
weight and become a grown woman no
longer overseen by the potential
disapproval of her parents she now
realizes the importance of someone who
is willing and wants to help and does
sleep with Paul this leaves us with the
thought that we should not be ashamed of
things such as this and should openly
seek out help from those that are able
to properly give it so that we can find
strength again to grow abuse is
something that will follow you your
entire life and some people who are
abused go on to abuse others thus
passing on is similar to how the
creature is passed from person to person
though this is never cemented in the
film it is confirmed to me by the many
appearances of the creature which not
only takes the shape of a woman who's
been clearly assaulted and it's
urinating on herself but also a fully
naked man all this leads into my other
theory which deals with what happened to
Jays father it's clear that he is absent
from the characters lives and though
Jays mother is obscured throughout the
majority of the film the very minor
parts that we do see her show her as an
alcoholic this leads me to believe that
Jays mother is struggling with the fact
that Jays father killed himself and this
could be because he was sexually
assaulted and could not live with it
juxtaposing this Jay confronts a and
thus is able to move on from what her
father could not there's also an
alternative theory that I've seen which
makes a lot of sense and basically flips
my prior theory on its head this is to
do with the stylistic choices of the
film that could be signifying where the
characters actually are now what's
excellent about it follows is that
there's an undercurrent throughout the
entire thing that something's not right
in the area this is purely down to the
fact that the time period of the movie
is impossible to pin down there's a
futuristic clamshell ereader and yet
there are vintage television sets
cause photos and kitchens this also
coupled with the fact that the seasons
don't make any sense in the introduction
of the film we see a young woman with
short shorts fleeing creature and based
off her look it's summer however we see
pumpkins on the porches and leaves on
the ground
we then see Jay and a swimming pool but
if it is autumn and this would be far
too cold to relax in when Jay visits the
cinema everyone is wearing a heavy
winter coat and it's clearly very cold
so why is she swimming out of the pot in
the film well this could be because the
characters all exist in either purgatory
or hell and the demon is simply tracking
and tormenting them for its own sick
desires this is why all of the film is
in its own time piece and why everything
fields off
this also backs up the fact that the
creature appears as the onlookers
subconsciousness if the entity was able
to choose a form freely and surely it
would be more covert the fact that it
appears as people that would easily
alert the onlooker suggests to me that
it's unable to do so and therefore
adapts to their subconscious this is why
it appears as Greg when Jay is looking
out of her window guarding our with the
character and why when it bangs on the
door it appears as Greg's mother as this
is who he would be expecting to see when
hearing the noise therefore we can take
from this that the characters are
trapped in their own personal hell's
unaware of what's going on exactly and
for still about eternity in fear to me
if follows is a masterpiece and
definitely one of the most underrated
horror movies of the last decade it's a
completely unique premise and due to its
aesthetic it's elevated above many other
films in the genre I could probably
spend an hour talking about the ins and
outs of this movie but hopefully this is
giving you a quick summary of things
that you can now take to go back and
watch the film with that will give you a
new perspective obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the movie and if
you agree with either theory or have
your own comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you subscribe to
the channel and check out my latest film
breakdowns which will be linked at the
end I probably start posting regularly
again in the next 10 days or so but me
and the wife of had to flee to Mexico
because there's a strange creature
following us and with all the best way
to get rid of it was to go to another
country it's walking very very slowly so
it should be okay anyway keep an eye out
for another classic ending explain
breakdown which should be out pretty
soon this is the channel for people who
were mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]